あお久しぶりですこんにちははじめしち
です
えお休み期間いただきましてえー帰ってき
まし
た休めませんでした休めませんでしたあの
活動休止とは言ってないので別にさその
動画出さないから何もしてなかったわけで
もないですしインスタとかXとかSNS見
てた方なら分かると思うんですけども結構
いろんなことしたり撮影したりなんか結構
色々動いてはいたのでそこが問題なんじゃ
ないかなとも思ったねお休みしますて言っ
たのにあの全然休めないしなんなら
忙しかったまであるなのでメイン
チャンネルの動画はこう止まってたんです
けれどもあの全く休めませんでした
ただいまですただメインチャンネルを更新
しなかったお休み期間中たくさん動画を
撮ることができたので動画はたくさん撮れ
ましたメインチャンネルありがとうござい
ますそれを撮りたくてちょっと休んでた
部分もあったので12月はこの後どんどん
動画出せていければいいんだと思ってるの
でお楽しみにはいもうねなんかでも色々ね
すっきりはした悩むと動画撮れないんです
よね特に人間関係とか色々こう悩んでた
ところがあったんですけどもそこら辺は
結構話したりとかこう時間を儲けたりして
結構解決はしてないけども解決には向かっ
ていったりとか一応進展はあったので脳が
忙しいみたいなのはちょっと良くなりまし
たし動画もたくさん撮れていますので今日
から復活させていただきますよろしくお
願いしますま短いように見えて実は10日
以上休んでたからなさすがに10日間何も
動画出なかったら心配されると思うので
まあまあまあまさすがにお休みしまて言う
べきだったぐらいの期間かな皆さん11日
ぶりですお久しぶりです人気してたはいと
いうわけで12月今年ももうわずかになっ
てしまいましたがはめ社長ですね毎年1
年間何か禁止するようにしてるんですよ
これまでの振り返るとこうお菓子禁止とか
お菓子ジュース禁止お米禁止とかラーメン
禁止とか本当に毎年いろんなものを禁止し
てるんですけれども今年の禁止あの禁止し
ますって言ってたんですけども何を禁止
するか言わずに実は12月まで来てしまい
ました今日それを発表したいと思います
はい皆さん何だと思いますでしょうはめた
長が今年1年間禁止していた
ものこれわかるかなついつい来いはい来
ましたお失礼し
ますああ踏んたあちょっとごめんなさい
休まないとあそっか休止します俺さ今年1
年間はい禁止してたじゃないですかして
ましたねえ周りで気づいてる人いたいな
いっすマジはいえでも本当にちゃんと禁止
してたよねマジでしてましたあるね例の
そうですよなんか皆さんにヒントとかあり
ますかまはじめさんの行動見てたら分かり
ますよねあのまどねまよくよく見ればって
ことえそうそうそうまだはじめさんの動画
をちゃんと見てたら気づくかもしれない
はいはいはいはい確かにそうだねうんはい
えでもよく見たらもちろん分かることでは
あるえ絶対分かりますもう明らかにね変化
として近くにいる後輩とかもわか
るっていうぐらいのことを禁止してたん
ですよさあ何だと思いますでしょうか
シンキングタイムいやそんなのいいから
早く言えてではそろそろ発表しましょう私
はめ社長今年1
年お風呂禁止生活してました
[音楽]
嘘です汚すぎますさすがにそんなことはし
てませんえ今年1年ですね実
はコラボ禁止してまし
た見返してみてください僕の動画僕の過去
動画見返してみてくださいま具体的には
コラボ禁止というよりYouTuber
動画クリエイターとのコラボを1年間禁止
しておりました違和感に気づいた人いるか
なそう見返すとね今年ねあの山田孝幸さん
とかYouTuberやめた後輩とか霊媒
師さんとか水着美女とかザ
YouTuberじゃない人とはもちろん
動画撮りましたけども実は今年1年ですね
YouTuberとコラボ禁止しており
まし
たちょっと待ってくださいはじめさん今
見返してみましたけどもはじめさん
HIKAKINさんとコボしてるじゃない
ですかそ禁止になってないじゃないですか
はじめさんヒカキさんとコラボしてるって
言うじゃないです
か僕の
2023年の1月の1発目の動画見て
くださいどうぞ誰1人俺以外はじめ社長
自分以外の人間のために自分の優先のを
下げることはない
ですhinさん以外Hiさん以外ヒカさん
以外はいこの意味としてはですねかこ
HIKAKINさんは覗くHIKAKIN
さんとだけは僕コラボオッケーにしてまし
たあのですねHIKAKINさんの誘い
だけは僕は絶対断りません全部癒してい
ますそこから飛べるろって言って僕イエス
て言います親はちょっと僕の中でも
クリエイターとよりあの人は神なのでこの
世が良さされるこう指針となるような人物
であるのでHIKAKINさんとのカラボ
だけはすいませんあの例外とさせてOkと
させていただきましたがそれ以外の動画
クリエーターYouTuber一切コラボ
しておりませんだからもうコラボというか
やってもなんか電話出たりとかそのレベル
そうだからね今年1年実は全然
YouTuberの絡みがなかったです
もちろん動画外であったりとかなんか動画
とは別のお仕事とか一緒にしたりすること
はあったんですけど一緒にねこの
チャンネルでお互いに動画を取り合ううっ
ていうのはもう全くしてませんでしたこれ
何でしたかて言うとうんなんだろうなんか
ねいろんな理由があったのよえっとまず1
つ目がえっと自分の力でちょっとやってみ
たかったというかなんだろうこうコラボ
するとねなんかお互いの視聴者がこう
コラボ効果でなんか一時的には伸びるん
ですけれどもなんかそれ果たして本当に
自分の数字なのかと本当にその力あるのか
なって思って結構でもけけだったよこれで
コラボ1年禁止してなんかめちゃくちゃ
数字落ちてもうなんか見るも無惨な状態に
なったらマジで終わっちゃうし結構賭で
はじめ社長の今の力ってどれぐらいなの
かっていうのちょっと見たくて1人見修行
じゃないですけども今年1年はちょっと
1人で頑張ってみようと思ってコラボ禁止
してましたまHIKAKINさんに関して
はもう親分と何回も動画撮らせていただい
てるしあの僕はもうあの射程のみなので
なんか新規コラボってわけでもないので
やぶな許してくださいやぶなラブ
っていう自分の力を見てみたかったって
いうのが1つ目で2つ目あのこれはもう
本当に僕の市場というか個人的な思いなん
ですけどもうあのYouTuberコラボ
多すぎYouTuberコラボ多すぎ
やろってあの思ってました去年か2年前
ぐらいからなんなら仲良ししたいのいや
仲良ししたいんだったらいいんですけど
なんか別に仲いいYouTuberはい
ますけどもなんか別に一緒に動画を撮り
たくてYouTubeやってるわけでも
ないしもちろん一緒に撮れれば面白いもの
取れるなっと思う時はコラボしますけど
なんかえそんなにコラボするみたいな
そんなにコラボするとコラボしない時
ちょっと寂しくないみたいななんか
YouTubeのチャンネルとかもあっ
たりしてなんかYouTube全体見た時
にこれなんかコラボしない方が個性出るん
じゃないかって思ってあえてちょっと閉鎖
的に立ち回っておりました別にコラボする
ことが悪いとは言わないですしお互い相場
効果でいいこともあると思うんですけど
やりすぎてるとなんかなん
だろうみんなでチャンネルやればいい
じゃんみたいなあの知なのでそんなにね
なんか突然いろんな人と動画撮るとかも
得意じゃないのでチャンネル同士のコラボ
とかじゃなくてなんかこう
YouTuberなんとか大会とかなんか
集めてYouTubeやったりとかなんか
個人的にはそういうのたまにでいいかなと
コラボってたまにするからきっとなんか
魅力に感じるし夢のコラボというかあそこ
とそこコラボするだすごい見たいってなる
と思うのでなんかね今年は1年コラボし
なかったですけども今後もコラボの頻度は
なんかちょっと考えながらやりたいなとは
思ってますたまにコラボするぐらいの方が
やっぱすごいコラボ動画に価値が出ると
思っててそういう思いもあって1年間
コラボしませんでし
たヒカキさんを覗くもう今12月ですけど
1年間これやってみてま数字的に
は大丈夫でした大丈夫でしたというかなん
だろうチャンネル登録者数も増えてるし
再生回数もまあまあまあ
あのコにはなりませんでした動画によって
波はあるけども伸びるがちゃんと伸びるし
なんかああ俺コラボしてなくてもいける
わっていう自信に繋がった1年だったと
思いますやっぱねこんだけコラボしないと
コラボしたいなっていう気持ちもあるん
ですけどもやっぱコラボしまくりたいって
わけじゃないんですけどもちょっとね
コラボは恋しくなりましたあのごめん
なさいねいろんなYouTuberの皆
さんいろんな人に誘っていただいたんです
けど全てお断りさせていただきました本当
にあの来年から仲良くしてくださいお願い
しますなんか色々いましたよ中にはもう
今年コラボ禁止なのよって言ってるも
ごり押しして本当にお願いしますみたいな
こと言ってくるやつもいたしあこっちの
ことどうでもいいんだみたいななんか
あんまりこっちのこと考えられてないなっ
て思うような人もいましたね正直に言い
ますけどコラボ禁止してるのは分かってる
んですけどお願いしますみたいないやいや
何言ってんのってもうこっちの都合完全
無視で本当に向こうがただ取りたいだけな
んだなっていうクリエーターもいて
ちょっと腹が立ったこともありました気を
つけた方がいいよあんまりいい思いしない
からそれはていうねちょっとその
YouTuberとしてはじめ社長って今
1人でどんだけ戦えるのかっていうのを
ちょっと見てみたいなとそしてなんかこの
コラボ市場主義というかコラボしないと
ダメですよ感のなんかYouTubeが
ちょっといけがさして抗ってみましたその
結果生き残れましたありがとうございます
気づいた気づきましたか皆さんはいという
わけで結構初め社長ブが聞いた1年だった
と思うんですけれどももう1ヶ月ぐらいか
なもう2023年ももう少しなので
いろんな動画を出して頑張っていきたいと
思いますま無理せず楽しく動画を出して
いければいいなとます今年も残りばがはめ
社長よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
じゃ